ever since the pandemic started and
jerome powell started the money printer
the stock market has only gone in one
direction up this has trained millions
of retail investors who started
investing during the pandemic to
constantly buy the dip if a stock sells
off three to five percent it's time to
buy and if a stock sells off 10
it's time to go all in
ironically when people buy these
quote-unquote discounts they're simply
investing at all-time high levels from a
few days or a few weeks ago so it's not
like they're really getting a discount
but we can't really blame them because
that's all they've seen
in fact throughout all of 2021 the s p
500 didn't even experience a single 10
correction the largest sell-off the
index saw last year wasn't even six
percent so it makes sense that many
retail investors have been trained to go
all in on even the slightest of
pullbacks many are even claiming that
this is simply the new normal and that
we'll never see another 40 or 50
correction in the stock market but this
is actually the most dangerous sentiment
to have because the tops of bubbles are
literally called the new paradigm so
here's the truth about stocks that don't
come back
starting off the list we have the
innovative companies or the growth
companies that have dominated the market
over the past two years
often these companies promise to
revolutionize how we do everyday tasks
for example instead of building up a
strong network of taxis that's easily
accessible these companies will promise
to provide you with self-driving cars or
instead of building more stores and
carrying more inventory close to where
you live the promise to deliver any
product straight to your doorstep
generally these companies have the best
of intentions but they don't have the
best of balance sheets so it just takes
a simple market downturn to wipe them
out completely take mark
cubansbroadcast.com for example in the
1990s broadcast.com allowed users to
stream audio and eventually even video
through the internet given that most of
us spend hours streaming podcasts music
videos and movies today this was clearly
a great idea and multiple hundred
billion dollar companies have been built
based on just dreaming one or two types
of media yahoo could see this future in
1999 and that's why they agreed to buy
broadcast.com for 5.7 billion dollars
but even yahoo could not sustain the
company through the dotcom crash and
they ended up shutting down one sector
after another until they shut down the
entire company another big bust from the
dakamera is pets.com
the idea of pets.com was simple sell pet
toys and food through the internet to
make these products more accessible and
convenient than ever before they had big
investors on board like amazon who at
one point owned half the company this
allowed pets.com to complete an
extremely successful ipo raising over
300 million dollars yet just 268 days
later they went bankrupt thanks to
dotcom crash
now pets.com was not a bad idea by any
means
chewie basically executed the same
concept a decade later and they're worth
nearly 20 billion dollars today so
clearly the idea doesn't really matter
when we're talking about a stock market
crash the only thing that matters during
a downturn is the balance sheet because
if a company can't survive the downturn
they'll never actually release their
quote-unquote revolutionary product or
service
and that's just two examples 52 percent
of all dot-com companies went to
bankrupt by 2004 and there's no doubt
that that included dozens of brilliant
ideas
so clearly simply investing in a company
with a good idea doesn't guarantee
investment growth in fact during the
dot-com bubble most of the time it
didn't
okay so betting on unprofitable
disruptors is basically just a gamble
but what if you're not investing in
unprofitable disruptors like rivien
lucide teledog and now dimension what if
you're investing in profitable
disruptors like tesla shopify and square
these companies will most likely survive
a multi-year bear market with no
additional funding so buying the dip on
these companies is relatively safe right
well if you hold long enough then
probably but you could also be looking
at several painful years ahead for
example take a look at dot com favorites
that actually survived and ended up
becoming big before amazon became a
trillion dollar ecommerce giant and
liberals started hitting jeff bezos
amazon went through the dot-com crash
and amazon didn't sell off 40 or 50 or
even 70
amazon sold off a painful 95
at that point you'd probably be
questioning if the company is going to
survive it regardless of how the balance
sheet looks but even if you stayed
invested you would have had to wait
seven years just to almost break even
and then the 2008 financial recession
would hit and you'd be down 70 on your
initial investment once again it was
until november of 2009 or 10 years after
the dot-com peak that you would actually
start making money on amazon another
great example is booking holdings
booking holdings was a travel booking
company that went parabolic during the
dot-com bubble and it is still around
today and it's doing better than ever
before but like with all companies that
were founded during the dotcom bubble i
had to first go to the dotcom crash and
this time we're not even talking about a
95 crash we're talking about a 99.36
crash this means that for every 100 you
invested into booking holdings you would
have just 64 cents or not even a dollar
left at the bottom of the crash to make
things worse it took booking holdings 14
years just to recover to its dot-com
peak
also it should be noted that even today
while booking holdings is at 2 000 a
share that's only a 2x from its dot-com
peak meaning that it took 25 years just
to double your money even just investing
in the s p 500 would have given you a
better return not to mention you would
have never been down 99.36
so while you may not lose money if you
go all in on a disruptor that survives
you could easily be waiting a decade
just to break even
okay so disruptors in general are
dangerous you could either lose it all
or you could end up waiting several
years just to break even but what if you
don't even mess with the disruptor or
growth stocks what if you're a blue chip
investor that only invests in the
largest and the most stable companies in
the world like apple microsoft and
google is it okay to go all in on dips
in this scenario well not really in fact
i'd say this is worse than going all-in
on a profitable disruptor with the
profitable disruptors you can be sure
that if the company is able to weather
the downturn they're probably going to
the moon once the market recovers the
same cannot be said about slower moving
large cap companies here's the thing
while we like to often complain about
companies being too powerful and having
too big of a monopoly companies don't
stay at their peak forever in fact if
you're gonna be deterministic about
anything in the stock market it should
be that companies come and go and with
the rise of technology and rapid
disruption the lifespans of companies
are getting shorter and shorter in fact
mckinsey and the company found that the
average time a company stays in the s p
500 is just 18 years considering this
they predict that 75 of companies that
are currently part of the s p 500 will
have disappeared by 2027 and even if
they don't disappear it's very likely
that they become a shell of their former
self in the 2000s the companies that
dominated the fortune 500 were ge exxon
procter and gamble dupont and so on and
so forth while these companies are still
around disruptors like apple microsoft
and amazon have grown to be 10 times
larger but wait a minute the market
giants of the past like ge and exxon
weren't tech giants so they had a tough
time keeping up with the tank companies
like apple and google should have a far
better shot at keeping up right
well this is not exactly true either and
the best example of this is cisco during
the dot-com bubble it wasn't just
speculative companies that got bit up
but also the biggest tech companies in
the world at the peak of the dot-com
bubble cisco became the world's largest
company boasting a market cap of 500
billion dollars if we adjust for
inflation that's 823 billion dollars
today since then 22 years have passed
yet cisco is yet to put in a new
all-time high in fact it's currently
still 32 away from its dot-com peak and
that's with cisco doing a bunch of stock
buybacks and trying to soften the
downfall if we just look at their market
cap it's currently less than 250 billion
dollars meaning that the stock has to
run over 100 just to reach their peak
market cap from 22 years ago and that's
not even accounting for inflation cisco
isn't just a one-off exception either
other top 10 companies that never
recovered include intel and at t who's
to say that apollo isn't the next cisco
i mean have you seen the last four
generations of iphones
only time will tell but just keep in
mind that going all in on tech giants
may not be as safe as you think
and finally that brings us to the index
fund investor if you're gonna constantly
go all in on every dip indices are
definitely what you want to be buying
but i suspect that most people who are
following into stocks aren't following
into index funds with that being said
though it's not exactly a good idea to
fill more into index funds either take
the nasdaq for example after the dot-com
bubble burst the nasdaq crashed a
whopping at 83
keep in mind that the nasdaq is a
combination of 100 of the largest and
most profitable companies on the market
yet it was able to crash 83 within a few
years and it took a long and drawn out
17 years to return to its dot-com peak
many of you guys watching probably
aren't even 17 years old if you invested
in the s p 500 instead you would have
had a better time but not by much
first you would have experienced a 50
crash along with the seven year long way
to return to all-time highs and adjust
when you think things are finally going
bullish again you're hit with the 57
crash that takes you to lower levels in
the dot-com crash and it's not until 13
years after your initial investment that
you finally start to make money so as
you can see if you go all in at the
wrong time you could still easily be
stuck for well over a decade even with
an index fund but at least you can be
sure that index funds will recover
sooner or later
right well michael berry seems to think
that index funds are actually in some
sort of crazy bubble themselves due to
the rise of passive investing and that
index funds are doomed to crash and not
recover but that's a whole other
discussion
so far we've gone through several
examples and hypotheticals but the
lesson at the end of the day is to just
not fomo into the market just because
the market dips 10 or 15 or 20 percent
doesn't mean that you should bet the
farm on an index or any individual stock
this type of behavior is what leads to
people losing money presenting the stock
market and missing out on the best
buying opportunity of the decade by the
time the stock market actually bottoms
they've either stopped investing or they
ran out of sears capital a long time ago
because they just kept buying it every
dip so what should you do it instead
well this is not financial advice but
the smartest course of action in my
opinion is simply a long-term weighted
dollar cost averaging strategy maybe
every week you invest 100 into the s p
500 this way regardless of what the
market is doing it you have at least
some money going into the market this is
extremely important because the only
risk that's bigger than following in at
the top is the risk you're taking by not
investing at all anyway going back to
the planet if the s p 500 is down over
10 from its all-time high maybe you
could cut back on spending and invest
200 per week and if it's down over 20
maybe you can live on sticks and bones
and invest 300 a week and so on and so
forth that's just one example of what
you could do there are several great
long-term strategies that you can
implement it doesn't really matter which
one you choose as long as you stick to
it don't let emotions alter your plans
and most importantly don't be
deterministic about anything as no
investment is too big to fall but that's
just what i think have you guys felt any
fomo in regards to the stock market
within the last two years comment that
down below also drop a like if this
video helped you realize how brutal the
stock market can be
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch your
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one